18 Syracuse University students face
possible expulsion over disturbing
videos of young men at a fraternity
engaged in offensive behavior a new
second video was published online over
the weekend it appears to show Theta Tau
members simulating a sexual assault on a
man in a wheelchair the University which
expelled the Theta Tau chapter said the
students made several offensive videos
to Rika Duncan is outside the fraternity
house in Syracuse New York where the
videos were recorded
Jericka good morning good morning all is
quiet here right now and there's a
public safety officer parked in front of
this house university officials say that
18 of those Theta Tau members have been
removed from classes and that today even
more members could face disciplinary
actions now that video is difficult to
watch but it was not released by the
University instead it was the student
newspaper the daily Orange that released
and obtained that disturbing video the
newest video surfaced Saturday and shows
what appears to be Theta Tau brothers
pretending to sexually assault a
disabled man in a wheelchair a video
released last week apparently shows
members joking about the Holocaust and
using racial and anti-semitic slurs
Syracuse University permanently expelled
the Theta Tau chapter over the weekend
and charged 18 students with undisclosed
offenses the students whom the school
will not identify because of federal
privacy law are banned from classes
during the disciplinary process they
will attend alternative study
arrangements instead Syracuse president
Kent syverud
outcomes could include suspension or
expulsion from Syracuse University
students are calling on the university
to release more of the fraternities
videos but civil route has so far
resisted saying he wants to protect the
integrity of the ongoing investigation I
was heartbroken
sophomore Priya Penner says she hopes
this
school will expel the students involved
this video is just a example one example
of what we deal with as marginalized
folks it's saying to them and to me that
disabled lives and disabled people
aren't worth seeing as people Theta Tau
members apologize for the video last
week which it said was intended to be
satire members say they don't really
hold the views that were expressed in
those videos meanwhile the Dean of
Students here at Syracuse says the
school will meet with some of the 18
students to decide on punishment Nora
where I Jericka thank you you know it's
not sad tired you know no it is not it's
not last week I thought you shouldn't
expel them you just work with them and
now you look at that video and I sort of
changed my mind on that and we know many
Syracuse students who certainly say that
does not represent the school that they
go to that's not indicative of how
people feel there but you can't do that
and say that doesn't reflect the person
that I am repeatedly you can't do that
yeah it wouldn't come out of your mouth
no absolutely would not